how's my girl
okay yeah i feel some kind of technology
i feel like all kinds of technology all
over all over me like like on you
all these people this has been like 10
years or most about five years of solid
um technology on mark but it's it's all
invalid you know it's it's not cool
it's all over him i could feel it so
yeah on his clothes feeling on this car
closing car and unmarked
does it even get to you i don't
yeah i need it
there you go
are you okay stand up really bad are you
okay yeah
i'm um every time they say you're okay
that's a that's a terrible
for something so
you know
needed
somebody to ask you are you okay
and they've programmed it like it's some
kind of freaking a meal ticket when i
say whatever i say just them saying it
um
you know all this stuff but
um
are you okay
you know
and then like
this dude in the kid you know that kia
silver man that comes and makes me up
it's like they make me want to get in
the van but i know it's not doing any
good for me
but i think it could if everybody knew
how to jump in the van and take over
you know it could be really beneficial
you know
not trying to get off you
how many how many days how many dates
will you pick up in a typical day
date so like
four about four or five four or five
that's how you survive yeah i survive on
dates
my dates you know what did those do to
me and then they got this thing on my
memory with my tracks and my you know my
mom used to say i've only got a
one-track mind
um
leave me alone or whatever but my tracks
in my memory they're bullshitting and
acting like my tracks
my memory are like
they've done something i don't think
they can do something they're just
blocking them
so all this stuff should be working
right now and it's it's really it's a
big deal
so i just hope
we could nail those people that are
blocking the tracks as well as keep on
throwing me in the wrong body and i know
they've made them want like as much as a
kid wanting their the bike for christmas
or the doll
or the
you know your most time you wanted a
christmas present
or one in a relationship whatever they
make these people want to get me out of
my body
it's tremendous i can feel it
because everybody does it including they
all do it
but
um
i don't even know how big i know this
tooth right here
it's like a big tooth you know
if i was hitting it that tooth
see it's starting
that tooth like it's like only thing i
have left i think in my body
might be or anything else that's left of
caroline francis
you know
hey you've lost some teeth
oh yeah and i've lost some teeth
so the dates you'll pick up how much do
you make per day
oh like 20 or 25 dollars for 20 20 25 40
and
i just really wish
that something would come about and
you're having sex with them or just uh
oh sex and blow jobs oh when they're
doing blow jobs they're taking the skin
out of my mouth and i could feel them
all
they're doing something in that forward
edge because that skin that they're
taking they're putting it right in their
mouth oh steve and alex
yeah those two are putting it right in
their mouth and doing something that
they need some emergency
they need to talk for him
you know i just kind of
think you know yeah you're doing this
with a condom
yeah
pretty much
but like you know i'm
i got super powers i can i can um i can
kill an
uh
an infection and things like that i
don't get a lot of stuff like that yeah
you don't get sick very often do you no
but i'm kind of getting a cold and so oh
really
yeah i can feel it through the night
last night it's just it's just like
[ __ ] though because it's like
it's like i'm
it's like i have a cold but it's it's
like
you know
it's just like you're staying in a tent
now
i got the brown circle tent
over there yeah you're one of my
neighbors here yeah so you're just if
you
if um
if this guy's stuff wasn't over blocking
there you could see it from right
outside your door yeah
you just walk in the middle of the
street and look that way and
clear all the blocks and you can see it
it's like a looks like a brown spider
do you have any friends caroline not
really i got my friends george
um
e
mike
and um um well i like l.a and them in
the store you guys and um
and oh they they busted a hole in my
forehead
my third eye
i i hope all this stuff can show man
just spray it with some kind of
something you know
could some people spray their stuff so
every part of this thing could be
how do you so beneficial are you
depressed
i'm just depressed about money i'm
depressed about i'm not being able to
know if my kids put back together
because they put people in pieces
now it could be
um believable that people
made these templates with super powers
and um
mysterious god works in mysterious ways
and and um and
majesty
and and charisma you know you say oh
this girl's got charisma at a party or
whatever but like
you know
all the shoes are acting like i have one
right now and so like you said
um but they took that to another level
and made me magic and then now
everybody's getting
using magic and charisma
but that that stuff goes down fast you
know just all the charisma go down you
know
and like charisma christmas
but i'm just not big enough i just i
need to get myself big enough to um
to
to to do something you know to to do
something
and i i hope my back they keep folding
up my spine
and making me equal and then everybody's
like on this whole equal thing they want
to make me equal with them and then they
want to take the leftovers
but this eagle thing is like really
because nobody's equal i'm sure you're
way up the ladder
mark
but you know
the meaning that uh of life your your
hands look better today you look better
you look
yeah you look better
you you could probably be my son
my my chosen son you look like my sister
maybe my sister you actually look like
my sister
yeah i look bad right when i first met
you i was married and i asked my wife
because i thought you were just like
so
like something like a lot of people i've
interviewed like we should save this
girl say this person
sometimes it's a guy sometimes it's a
girl and i said to my wife like what do
you think of
putting this woman caroline who's a
heroin addict in the guest house and
trying to get her clean and she goes
i don't think that's a good idea
yeah that wouldn't work because i just
would have come right back out but i
appreciate that
yeah but i've
you you were the very first person i
ever interviewed
you got those whole things going for me
really yeah
and so um
as far as um that
you've been at this for how long it's
like 12 years about 12 years i took a
few years off i had to go get a divorce
oh he had to go get a divorce okay
yeah those are messy divorces i wonder
if it's my bra that's making me feel
this way uh seeing if i could take off
my bra but just underneath my shirt just
trying to
there i just feel really awkward today
because they're pulling on something and
um they're using my pull and it's
that's just getting so big you know this
thing
how do you feel today i feel great thank
you you feel good
do you sleep at night yeah i slept last
night in my tent
how many hours were you sleeping tonight
i slept i slept a long time i've made
myself go back to sleep this morning
when i would have gotten up early and go
sleep through all the sirens and all the
noise yeah
yeah i do but um i know i'm surrounded
by these tents
and um
you know i think i'm getting victimized
from the tents i tried to show it
earlier but um
yeah i guess i need to pull myself to me
really important
to pull caroline to caroline like
pulling mark to mark you know
and um
that might help
because all these people have just torn
me up man
[Music]
oh it's fun
sorry for when i first saw you down here
12 years ago i was like what the hell
are you doing down here
you just didn't you seemed to stick out
like a like you didn't belong down here
you didn't know what i was you know well
i mean i
you were just somebody i photographed i
wasn't doing interviews at the time
and then eventually
what do people see when they see you
like that looks like me um you guys up i
mean i'm just wondering you know do they
see a supernatural they see a child or a
brother
relative of a supernatural immortal
and what
what do you guys
you know get mark to mark right now
because i'm sitting here in front of him
somebody's got some kind of bs trying to
i'm act like they're ahead of me
trying to act like um you we can't get
mark here
and um
i just want to know what they see when
they see me or mark what how they know
that these people are connected
and if
there's connections between the people
they have in possession of mark because
i know there's something going on with
that too they've never said it because
it didn't need to come up in the past
six months i keep really hammering it
just waiting for something to come about
but you know to
what drugs do you play around with now i
just i only smoke um bla i smoke um
heroin and um i i i smoke some crystal
too sometimes is that correct
crystal not crack anymore no i could
crack
all together i haven't had any crack i
took a couple hits the other day but not
nothing i never got back on it
and you can differentiate differentiate
between uh fentanyl and
heroin
i don't think i can differentiate oh
well i mean of course because i know the
taste of my stuff
but
but there's a lot of fentanyl but i
especially heard people keep talking to
me about fentanyl you know but i i've
never tried it i've never smoked it on
foil
i've never tried any fentanyl
nor have i ever done any needles one
time these people tried to jab me with a
needle
like muscle
heroin but i didn't i've never been a
needle user
i don't
i don't do you talk with your daughter
anymore
yeah i just talked to her about last
week um
where was she she was um
she was um
i forget what she was doing
oh no i talked to her one night she was
at some vietnamese noodle place with her
friend
and then the other time i talked to her
she was um
oh i can't remember what she was doing
i'm sure she misses you she's working
for now in malibu which is my
ex-boyfriend's nephew she's back in the
later wife yeah she's she's in l.a
i hope she's not in hell for these
people i got worried about that last
night
and i started to sing this hymn from
church that um you know
because he lives i can face tomorrow
because because but i'll sing because
she lives
all fear is gone because i know
i hold the future
and life is worth a living just because
they live i was trying to bring back all
the people that had been done dirty like
my daughter and other people you know
just like
you know trying to bring these people up
say whoever thinks they're so important
and the boss
it ain't going to happen and i'm going
to keep on pulling these people out and
awaken them awakening them
and you know whatever locks they think
they have on and i just the one thing
i'm worried about are those when i'm in
that kia van
um
see they have this stuff on way bigger
than what i am so if i just said um for
the size i am you know
to get
get get these i do this a lot too and i
don't know what they've done with that
they might have extended it out and
either way
um
i need this thing to get smaller for for
everyone you know for mark if mark's in
there or whoever's in mark or whatever i
wanted them all to stand up and say um
what am i doing in this body why who am
i and um and i i wouldn't have done this
to caroline
i know it seems like i'm a world uh
dominator but i'm really not you know
i'm starting to see what this thing's
about
i'm talking for you guys
and i i'm curious about some things i
hope you get the answers of those things
today
yes have you found any answers down here
on skid row we've been here a while
all these things i'm talking about yeah
just um what's going on i mean
would this have happened to me if i was
in malibu
yeah
yeah on a different in a different way
but they were doing this before i got
here
packing me with technology and putting
transfers and
when i say about the transfers and the
forwards people get
you know
weirded out because they it's turned
them into a different person it's made
them make money they have you know they
have a personality so you know
when all this stuff they have i'm just
wondering what
why
when it's going to turn to okay [ __ ] it
i don't need these transfers i'm i need
to get the lord back to herself and and
the people
uh back there
all these things that are on the wall
this
home love family relationships together
marriage smiling respect
personalities and honesty for
unity and warmth in the right way
traditions and kind
adoration memories
and um
but um
the food
it takes for you to have one little bit
of food that you have um this food you
know
looking at people's wherever in their in
their stomach and their body that they
they need they need food
you know they they eat food they buy
organic and all these expensive foods
are they even getting it i hope they can
get some of this food in the right
places
right now you know because once that
food goes in
and they do block stuff but there's
certain things they can't block and i
hope those things go today i need that
today in the water too
where do you eat
what do i eat where do you eat oh where
i was eating in my tent this morning you
buy food from one of the restaurants
here um i buy food from catch 21 i buy
food at whole foods i buy um you go to
whole foods i go i go to whole foods i
buy yogurt
and occasionally i bought i bought some
peanuts there the other day i packed
just the 299 dry roasted peanuts you're
still a malibu girl
yeah well i you know i like heirloom
tomatoes i don't buy tomatoes please
because these this place on the corner
over there at six and where i just was
on sixth in
uh san pedro
they have one you can take the girl out
of malibu you can't take the metal gear
out of the girl yeah you can't take this
but i eat my tent i was eating cereal
frosted mini wheats
and uh
rock view milk but i i started using
this other milk that they gave out in
the food bank this morning
but they said something about the
cigarettes i had a i bought a pack of
cigarettes montana 100s
two nights ago
and all of a sudden they said george was
trying to um
was trying to steal my anatomy
and um
but i know george
at the last minute george isn't is not
going to do that he just won't do that
because he knows they'd put him on it
he he doesn't have all the facts right
now of how and why he he's mystified
that why are they choosing me i'm just
this little short guy a dope dealer you
know street peddler
what you know
but i always try to throw in things to
george i don't know if he's sitting
there i was trying to say well you're
probably part of me you know my kid or
my grandparent or whatever
you know from my sister somehow he fits
in there the little leprechaun
black leprechaun but he's golden colored
too so it's not really that black color
like blanket or for him he looks he's
golden so you know it could be gold i i
don't know
i just know my ears they keep covering
me with these
please somebody get these connections
off me man
the connections of um covering me with
stuff i wasn't even breathing on
well i started getting real stuffed up
nose we're like
i'm pretty messed up today i may go to
the hospital today for what
just to tell them i
feel like i have a cold
just for whatever they can do to for all
this technology all over me
are you lonely
lonely
uh yeah but you know
only i i don't have a lot of time to be
lonely because i'm worried about all
this technology
and um
no i'm not lonely
and i'm not afraid they keep me um
there's nothing you're afraid of
well i get scared and stuff about this
whole thing about
us people ascending in my place i don't
like that at all
and you know
i'm not really fearing about going to
hell or anything
unless i'm there but either way um it'll
work itself out
you know if you have any thoughts of
that kind of stuff i'm not going to
leave you in hell
what would you say is the most important
thing you've learned in your
you know how do you carolyn 50.
what's the most important thing i've
learned
to
intuitively
get information through
great people
the way i do which is not by talking to
them
to open myself up to um
people
to get me the information i need
and get the information out there and
they're blocking everything but
we're above that why don't you get up
above that now
you know
these people want to lie and act like
you're down
there go up
and get this information out
i think it should go to the middle
it looks like you get the information
out
bring the information to the middle
is
you know untwisting this
like that type of thing you know um
well they say the father son the holy
spirit
where is it on me you know i'm caroline
francis
the father son the holy spirit on
caroline caroline france says
where would that be you know and it
somewhere here and the omniscience and
the um omni
get these people's [ __ ] omnipresence
they made using my words or my my
mouth's got this full rigging thing on
here
taking my word
you know these strings and um i keep on
saying to get rid of them i don't know
who is the buster
that keeps on bringing them out man and
how where's all my importance my my um
honor my respect is it hidden in here
or you know
could it could you see see-through like
to it you know
could
the respect and honor and my food and my
spring my stomach so you could see it in
that lens get all the blocks off that
lens
from the beginning of this talk you know
we might just have us a good
a good interview here even though it
looks kind of
and then all the blocks on me i guess
any block that would be um stopping
these words from getting out that would
it would um
on my fingers and
stomping on my all the blocks on every
level you know
to get this thing um
right
and then um
my everybody's ankles are engaged i
think in my family i hope those in
ankles can get unengaged in
positions and doggy style
and get them just acting like they get
their way when i'm doing um sex doggy
style
that that did a lot and orgasms
you know
don't think for a minute they haven't
used everything they could they could
get to you know
my lips
people doing stuff with my mouth and my
um my nose
and controls in my my spine
and my posture
and my uh potency my
polarity and my uh
profile
[Music]
all the profiles of us you know
very important
and um in my um
my breath
thank you very much
how's my girlfriend oh good uh well
it's been a it's been a long weekend it
was really cold but um you know
things it's gonna rain tonight it's
gonna rain tonight so i got to put a
tarp on my tent that's my tent right
there you wanna show me your time yeah
you wanna see it
yeah
they they vandalized me the other night
they sprayed me and they they just they
just made it over it but
it's right here but
it's really messy
there's only just a strip of a
place that i can sleep right here i've
got a bunch of bags here can you show me
the inside or no
i'll show you
you're sweet
i know it's a lot to ask
thank you caroline
thank you thank you for showing me your
house thank you white underbelly i know
you caroline you are the very first
person i ever interviewed down here
thank you yeah
you're the reason for this channel i
think thank you you guys and keep
watching and um i'll i'll have some good
stories for you soon
i just i'm worried about your your
safety yeah oh yeah i know it's
dangerous out here there's a lot of
predators there's a whole predator thing
going on we're going to get into that
we figured it out something to do with
pipes and brillo and poogie pipes and um
and crystal
and um could can be that fentanyl stuff
i don't really know but i know there's
some predators what drugs are you using
now i use a tar heroin
but your tear one probably has uh
fentanyl in it
i hope it doesn't i don't i don't want
to do fentanyl i don't want to try
something i'll bet you if you were
tested you'd probably have fentanyl in
your system yeah well maybe we'll take a
test but i don't want to start something
that stuff costs a lot more than what i
do
but that's my little sanctuary that's
i'm dealing with all this stuff but it's
the only thing that kind of perks me up
and gets me going and
my emotions and
it just helps me to to deal with this
stuff
out here because it's so crazy
and the money
the money to pay for that you make by i
i'm uh i'm a lady of the night in the
morning and lady of morning noon and
night yes here we go
you're you're my closest neighbor now
but i love having you as my neighbor but
i just um i you know i i think mark's a
really great guy i always always knew he
was i don't like people taking him over
in them so that's just just be just know
that um this possession thing and this
remote and um you know you crowd a bunch
of people around acting like you're
there to you know get money or whatever
i know what's going on here and um i
think i think you're the only person who
ever came up to me and gave me money one
day i gave you remember that i'll never
forget it yeah you came up to me you
gave me like
2.60 or something i wanted him to know
that i appreciate the money that he
gives me and um and
i think people should really appreciate
that and um turn away from evil
and money offerings to do certain acts
of because mark's very vital to me in
this whole street
you know
thank you very much thank you
you